je me souviens d'un procureur qui m'a
dit il y a quelques temps que la justice
elle était toujours trop dure pour
soi-même et toujours trop laxiste pour
les autres il y a beaucoup de préjugés
sur notre justice soit une justice
laxiste c'est une justice qui jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et surtout il y a quelques
années était profondément en souffrance
apparemment de moyens et depuis 5 ans
maintenant on réarme la justice on lui
redonne des moyens pour être plus rapide
parce qu'un des principaux reproches qui
est fait à la justice française c'est
qu'elle est pas assez rapide ce texte il
reprend les conclusions des états
généraux de la justice sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat ça va être 7,5 milliards
supplémentaires cumulés c'est énorme
c'est inédit et ça ça va nous permettre
d'aller plus vite de mettre en place un
certain nombre de choses qui permettront
d'avoir une justice encore plus proche
des citoyens et au-delà de ça c'est
surtout du recrutement plus 10000
recrutement c'est pas rien et puis aussi
les moyens technologiques faut pas les
oublier aujourd'hui sonoriser un lieu
mettre des caméras dans un lieu c'est
déjà possible dans notre texte on va
rendre possible des nouvelles techniques
d'enquête parce que les voyous ils sont
et les bandits ils ont aussi beaucoup
évolué et ils détournent complètement
aujourd'hui c'est les moyens qui avaient
la police à disposition jusqu'à
maintenant nos pauvres policiers
essaient de poser des balises sous les
voitures et autres Auris de faire choper
il faut qu'on donne les moyens vraiment
entre autres à nos forces de l'ordre de
pouvoir lutter contre les grands
délinquants on a mis des garanties plus
fortes que sur les anciennes techniques
d'enquêtes spéciales qui vraiment
nous éloigne très très largement de ce
que certains ont dénoncé comme étant
Bing Brothers évidemment tout le monde
ne verra pas son téléphone susceptible
d'être déclenché à distance ça concerne
des affaires qui sont des affaires de
grands banditisme de criminalité
organisée et de terrorisme on n'est pas
du tout sur un sur des écoutes de
masques puis 30 ans 40 ans notre système
judiciaire est complètement à l'abandon
et vraiment souffre dans tous les
domaines la justice dans ce pays était
la variable d'ajustement c'est à dire
que quand on devait faire des économies
on se disait allez on met pas un centime
de plus dans le budget de la justice
c'est tout ce contraire qu'on a fait
depuis six ans et on va continuer encore
pendant les quatre années qui viennent